welcome to a special edition of sin city
chronicles it is a big day for las vegas
with the raiders kicking off their
season with fans in the stadium but
before the team takes the field let's
take a look back at the history of
professional football in las vegas and
we start 53 years ago from 1965 to 1969
there was the continental football
league and in 1968 the las vegas cowboys
arrived games were played at cashman
field they lasted two seasons before the
league folded now here's a cool fact
hall of famer kenny stabler one of the
greatest quarterbacks of all time played
two games in the cfl before joining the
raiders in 1994 we had the las vegas
posse who were part of the canadian
football league touchdown they played at
sam boyd stadium it only lasted one
season attendance guys it was bad the
lowest attended game which was 2300 fans
remains a record low for the cfl now in
1994 we also had the las vegas sting who
were part of the arena football league
games were played at the mgm and thomas
and mack the sting lasted two seasons
until
four attendants caused a move to anaheim
ladies and gentlemen
this
is the access
yeah
let's go to 2001 in the arrival of the
xfl and the las vegas outlaws the team
went four and six in their first season
and they had multiple nationally
televised games the xfl folded after one
season from 2003 to 2007 it was the las
vegas gladiators they were part of the
arena football league the team went 31
and 50 in their five seasons and made
the playoffs once in 2008 the team moved
to cleveland and we end with our most
successful team the las vegas
locomotives who were part of the united
football league they started in 2009 and
played four seasons winning the
championship their first two games were
played at sam boyd stadium and during
the last season guess what attendance
was bad one game had 601 fans sam boyd
holds 40 000 people i don't think
attendance will be an issue tonight and
that is it for your sin city chronicles
rocky thank you